de la citronnade de l'orangeade bien
fraîche du parfait
bonjour françois et moi nous avons
préparé un petit goûter à casimir
monsieur du snob et le facteur qui sont
en train de vider de quoi faire un
championnat de pétanque
salut vous avez devant vous le champion
de pétanque de l'île aux enfants
je viens d'écrabouiller monsieur du snob
le facteur ils sont encore dans les
buissons en train de chercher leurs
boules
mais julie nous a préparé un petit
goûter une c'est très gentil
donc
je mangerais bien quelques amandes tout
de suite seulement elle va vouloir que
j'attende les autres
ça fait rien profitons qu'elle ne soit
pas là
des petits gâteaux au chocolat
spécialement préparée par france
il y a des chips des amandes les
cacahuètes du gâteau ça ira
si ces petits gâteaux en l'air
extrêmement appétissant cependant je ne
peux pas résister une fois les gouttes
tout de suite et
ils sont délicieux la voilà
sur la malle
à la voilà
il ya aussi des belles chips coustillac
non non il faut vraiment que je les
gouttes également jeu tellement fin que
voulez vous
voilà juste un peu
je crois qu'il vaut mieux que je ne
reste pas là et que je revienne à à
l'heure du goûter
je suis épuisé je crois que j'ai mérité
de m'asseoir en les attendre
qu'est ce qui s'est passé
il reste la moitié
dans les assiettes
salah
je me demande qui peut être le coupable
kazinian le facteur il ils sont aussi
gourmand l'un que l'autre et je n'aime
pas de preuve
alors françois
françois voudrais-tu demandé aux
détectives mais rock falls de me
rejoindre chez casimir immédiatement je
compte sur toi c'est urgent
derrière mon temps quelle audace
les
voilà mr locales laissent le puis-je
faire pour toi d'abord prend tout de
suite la voix de merlot forme si
quelqu'un nous observent
jeu petite mam'zelle gelli y aurait-il
une jolie énigmes à résoudre
parfaitement monsieur maroc falls
j'étais en train de préparer un petit
buffet et quelqu'un s'est permis de me
dérober la moitié du contenu des
assiettes
écoutez c'est ce et des dieux le monde
elle vient et édition du genre à craquer
quelques-unes certains vous attend comme
tout le monde j'ai maigri mais dévoile
ses de retrouver le coupable
d'ailleurs j'ai un moyen très sûr tenez
regardez de monsec les mélismes regardez
j'ai toujours avec moi quelques nous
aident et quelques vides ça par exemple
à quoi vous sert tels que me mets à
attraper le château du rayon déco fraude
je mets quelques mails dans la nuit deux
cuves de vue
voulait les kidnapper tu fais de vue je
mets ma main dans l'ouverture j'attrape
les amendes exactement il faut prendre
les mêmes pour effet mais votre mais qui
devient alors un groupe où es tu assures
essayer maintenant de retirer les merdes
je ne peux pas vous vous êtes pris vous
n'êtes plus un piège oui mais il me
suffit de lâcher les amendes et mama
redevient la finma non plus bon gros
poids et voilà tout écoutez j'ai entendu
dire qu'on prenait les petits singes de
cette façon ils ça m'étonnerait qu'un
humain soit assez stupide pour se
laisser attraper ainsi ce qui était
devenu lé goût main et est
allé faire un petit tour et un résultat
vous y jouez du résultat de matic
et tu ranges technique
et
au mois deux heures que j'attends et
personne ne s'est encore montrée mais je
l'avais partir car un petit os et après
j'espère que le gouvernement sera pris
au piège
non monsieur duchesneau bon dira ce
qu'on voudra mais la pétanque est un
sport tas atika à qui le dites-vous au
moins 1000 car il ne suffit pas de
lancer sa boule et soit elle a récupéré
1 et vérifier le point et chercher
symbole sans compter les expéditions à
quatre pattes pour ramasser les bulls
a heureusement que notre chère julie
nous a préparé un petit encas qui va
nous remonter le moral paraguay et
regardez dit elle a tout mis dans des
noix de concours en voit que c'est
rigolo t'amusant à notre cher ami à
l'art de présenter les chaussettes avant
que vous l'avez vous pas pont sur
charbon nous monsieur d'histoire
boucherville la correction existe nous
attendons les autres au juste un tout
petit peu son identité ça ne changera
pas à moi c'est rêver vous êtes un
tentateur je prends une amende le plus
digne de moi
je me prends mon gâteau attention un pas
deux un seul a aussi promis on seulement
à leur regard prenons les ensembles
ensemble
monsieur du snop on ne peut plus retirer
ma de la noix de coco mais moi aussi
mais qui est diabolique on
entend du bruit
trop tard mais tout doucement trop tard
c'est joli suivi par quasi biblique
comme souleymane poko derrière notre dos
et attendons tranquillement
voulait dire merci oui
déjà la wii nous nous brûlions de
patience de répondre à votre gracieuse
invitation de données je les ai battus à
plate couture c'est moi qui remportait
la coupe du vainqueur mais monsieur mes
allocs femme ce n'est pas arrivé ici si
susi julie je suis là
j'ai eu le site et inigo juge monsieur
dix neuf jours monsieur café et bien
écoutez ne me laissait pas le main est
tendue comme ça dans les ailes temps des
mois les vosges pour un amical chekade
bonjour ce
[Musique]
prix vous est pris le même temps les
noix des quelques heures
après non c'est une regrettable méprise
voulions goûter un tout petit peu
pleurions dix ans en tout cas c'est
formidable le coût de la noix de coco
seulement moi dans la même situation
j'aurais été plus malins ne me serais
pas laissés prendre
qu'auriez-vous fait je le sais cuisiner
et bien j'aurai fait
ceci
et cela
casimir doit tout manger qu'est ce que
je vais offrir à mes avis que moi et
voilà tu en as tu en voilà ce que tu vas
leur offrir ça que j'ai dans mon panier
je ne suis quand même pas cruel au point
de laisser mourir mes amis de faim
à propos de ce forum est mieux du snob
et le facteur sont innocents c'est moi
tout à l'heure qui est chipé dans les
assiettes
casimir c'est très bien de rétablir la
vérité c'est beau succès c'est bon
j'espère que toi pour tes casimir et
comment aussi vient de ma réserve
secrète
regardez il y à des amendes allant de
cologna ou
l'autre des chips 1 à l'huile de foie de
morue
ici des gâteaux au robinet
[Musique]